and
davis smith and kris benson luis who I
know who just
and if you have it
and dance who
knows, it
's nate to shoot whoever gropes you
I love you baby
I'm taking me
baby
from Chile
what a
hit
on social life of america baby
[Music]
remains  For me, if he calls it, the vision
deflates, he loses,
and if Bryant
knows
where it is, they don't have to shoot people, he
just lets you see,
I'll take the package,
if you want
this, feel the snub,
chirinos,
why
lexington,
shut up, let him sing to me, I want
[Music]
webó com mx bad
you  takes
only
those who don't have d'esquadra those
for whom baby
took me is the label that wants
baby
from filesa direct
what
do you want baby
I want to see you
it's me baby
in those hours
[Music]
I want nobody
's spell
[Music]
[Applause]